right now a nationwide search is
underway for 35 year old samantha moreno
rodriguez her picture right behind me
here
she is the mother of that boy found dead
more than a week ago now near mountain
springs trailhead just outside of las
vegas
police were calling him john little zion
doe he has now been identified as
seven-year-old
liam houston from san jose bianca holmen
is live now at metro headquarters with
the very latest developments good
morning bianca
good morning alex i was here when metro
released a digitally enhanced photograph
of liam
and it was that picture that a family
friend in san jose
recognized that family friend went to
police there in san jose
and that police department got in touch
with metro they were able to make a
positive identification
through using a piece of liam's clothing
so this is the timeline that we have so
far
based on the information shared by metro
yesterday
police say liam and his mother left san
jose on may 24th
on may 26th they can be placed in the
laguna beach area
and in victorville later that afternoon
liam's body was discovered on may 28th
in mountain springs
the next day moreno rodriguez's car was
seen traveling on i-70 near grand
junction
police say she was last seen on may 31st
checking herself into a denver area
hotel
metro believes she's traveling alone and
they need help from local hotels
please check their hotel register for
the days
of the 27th and 28th to see if samantha
checked into a hotel here in the las
vegas valley
here's another look at samantha moreno
rodriguez and the vehicle police believe
she's driving
again it's a dark blue dodge caliber
with license plate
6 wlh211 and we're told that it's also
packed with belongings
again anyone with any information is
asked to call crime stoppers where you
can remain anonymous
or you can of course call metro
reporting live from metro headquarters
bianca holman 8 news now